Herzlich willkommen zum "Q&A"
zur Reportage "Faszination Bunker".
An erster Stelle
ein grosses Dankeschön
für das Lob
und die vielen Komplimente.
Das freute mich sehr.
Umso mehr freut es mich,
dass ich viel Feedback erhielt
von Leuten, die auf Wanderungen
auch solche Bunker gesehen haben
und dieselbe Faszination verspüren.
Fabian Termin schreibt z.B.:
Seine Kinder
begleiten ihn auf Wanderungen
und versuchen immer,
einen mystischen Bunker zu entdecken.
Ich bin also nicht der Einzige, der
ein geheimnisvolles Gefühl verspürt.
Ihr habt selbst
viele Geschichten erlebt.
Z.B. im WK, in der RS
oder im Militär in einem Bunker.
Wie z.B. Patrick Kurzmeyer,
der schreibt:
Das findet auch Luke. Er schreibt:
Ich weiss nicht,
wie gemütlich es wirklich ist,
wenn man tagelang
kein Sonnenlicht sieht.
Das sagt auch Para Diver,
der bei den Festungstruppen war
und die RS in Mels absolvierte.
Er hat nicht so schöne Erinnerungen
wie Luke und Patrick.
Ich stelle mir das
sehr schwierig vor.
Ich war für etwa 1 1/2 Std.
in Erichs Bunker.
Kurz vor Schluss gingen wir
durch den Notausgang raus.
Und bereits dann hatten meine Augen
Mühe, sich ans Licht zu gewöhnen
und wieder draussen zu sein.
Wenn man tagelang eingesperrt ist
und kein Tageslicht sieht,
spürt man das schon, glaube ich.
Es ist schon sehr speziell.
Haller Hans schrieb,
dass er seine gesamte Dienstzeit
in Bunkern verbrachte.
Ich fragte mich, wie es war, dass
er das niemandem erzählen durfte.
Der Bau dieser Bunker war ja geheim.
Auch dass man in einem Bunker
stationiert war, war geheim.
Ich fragte ihn, wie das war.
Er war Geschützführer
und durfte am Anfang nicht einmal
das Munitionsmagazin sehen.
Denn man wollte nicht,
dass zu viele Leute z.B. wissen,
wie viele Granaten
dort gelagert waren.
Sein Vater war im Aktivdienst
und sprach ihn erst darauf an,
nachdem er erfahren hatte,
dass sein Sohn im Réduit tätig war.
Das ist total absurd.
Weiter schreibt er:
"Einrücken in den WK fand immer an
einem Bahnhof oder Sammelplatz statt,
und zwar
unter sog. Kriegsbedingungen."
"Von da an war alles tabu. Nur wir
selber wussten, wohin es weitergeht."
"Ich könnte Ihnen heute
so viel berichten."
Diesen Erfahrungsbericht
finde ich auch sehr spannend.
Es gab noch einige Fragen
zum Bau der Anlagen, z.B.:
"Wer war überhaupt am Bau beteiligt?"
"Zivile Firmen, das Militär
oder evtl. sogar Milizsoldaten?"
Jamalito fragt:
Das war eine Frage,
die ich armasuisse stellte.
Armasuisse ist zuständig für die
Stilllegungen und Käufe aller Bunker.
Sie hat aber verzichtet,
diese Frage zu beantworten.
Unter Jamalitos Frage schrieb jemand,
dass es private Firmen waren.
Leider konnte ich nicht viel Weiteres
dazu herausfinden.
Denn armasuisse wäre die
Anlaufstelle gewesen für diese Frage.
Para Diver fragt:
Diese Frage
habe ich armasuisse auch gestellt.
Auch hier verzichtete sie
auf eine Antwort.
Als ich in Erichs Festung war,
stellte ich ihm diese Frage:
Glaubst du
an die Effektivität des Réduits?
Ja, es war eine Abschreckung.
Wenn du weisst,
dass der Gegner gut bewaffnet ist
und du viele Leute
und viel Ausrüstung verlierst,
dann überlegst du dir zweimal,
ob du angreifst.
PHI Marketing fragt:
Ich weiss ehrlicherweise nicht,
wie man Sonne und Wind
in einem Berg effektiv nutzen kann.
Aber Wasserkraft wird gebraucht.
Das gesamte Grimselgebiet
ist wie ein ausgehöhlter Käse.
Die Kraftwerke Oberhasli AG begann
1925, dort Wasserkraftwerke zu bauen.
1941 wollte die Schweizer Armee
dort eine Festung bauen.
Es gab Einsprachen
der Kraftwerke Oberhasli AG,
da sie es nur für Wasserkraft
nutzen wollte.
Sie einigten sich dann aber.
1998, nach allen Kriegen,
gab die Armee all die Festungen auf.
Kraftwerke Oberhasli AG kaufte dann
die Festung Grimsel von der Armee.
Diese Infos habe ich aus dem Buch
"Die Schweiz unter Tag"
von Jost Auf der Maur
und von der Website
festung-oberland.ch -
ein Archiv von allen Festungen
und Bunkern und deren Geschichten.
Cirtap1 schreibt:
Danke, cirtap1.
"Analog zum Munitionsdepot
in Mitholz."
Auch dieses Frage
stellte ich armasuisse.
Sie verzichtete wieder
auf eine Antwort.
Alex Lussi, der Pilzzüchter,
gab mir dazu ein paar Infos.
Bevor er die Anlage kaufte,
prüfte er sie auf Munitionsrückstände
und andere Schadstoffe.
Sonst müsste man die Finger
von so einem Objekt lassen.
Armasuisse schreibt auf
ihrer Website, dass sie versuche,
schädliche und lästige Auswirkungen
auf die Umwelt zu verhindern
beim Rückbau
oder einer Stilllegung der Anlagen.
Dann TimiTurner06:
Das stimmt.
In der Reportage sagte ich bereits,
dass ich selbst eine grosse
Faszination für Bunker hege.
Ich bin oft auf Wanderungen
oder Motorradtouren.
Ohne zu übertreiben, sehe ich jedes
Mal, wenn ich in den Bergen bin,
einen Bunkerein- oder -ausgang,
eine Schiessscharte,
oder etwas, das auf einen Bunker
oder eine Festung hinweist.
Ich fragte mich jedes Mal:
"Was ist da drin? Wird das
noch gebraucht? Was ist das?"
Meine Neugier wurde immer grösser
und ich wollte dem nachgehen.
Deshalb machte ich
eine Reportage daraus.
Gigler_69 fragt:
"Arbeitest du weiterhin beim SRF,
oder war das etwas Einmaliges
während deiner Zeit
bei 'Zwei am Morge'? Top Doku."
Vielen Dank, Gigler_69.
"Zwei am Morge" gibt es nicht mehr,
aber für "rec." mache ich ab und zu
noch eine Reportage.
Zum Schluss: Viele von euch
wünschten sich einen zweiten Teil.
Das würde ich natürlich
sehr gerne machen.
Was wollt ihr denn gerne in
einem allfälligen zweiten Teil sehen?
Interessiert euch
der geschichtliche Hintergrund,
oder wollt ihr einfach
weitere absurde Bunkeranlagen sehen?
Schreibt es mir in die Kommentare,
denn das würde mir für einen
allfälligen zweiten Teil helfen.
Vielen Dank,
und bis zur nächsten Reportage.